portable versatile and powerful no
matter which one you buy the ipad and
its lineup can probably handle most
actions like reading ebooks watching
movies and shows like netflix and hbo
to writing and other office work playing
games and designing digital art with the
apple pencil what's up my fellow geeks
this is claire bringing you an
interesting video that many folks might
be thinking about if you're like me and
already own an apple tablet like
this 6th generation ipad you're probably
wondering how this compares to the new
4th generation ipad ad as a regular
procreate user myself i will give you
the lowdown on which ipad is best for
you budding procreate artists first of
all the ipad is not the most affordable
illustration device out there but if
you're looking to get one for yourself
let us help you figure out whether this
device is worth your bang for buck i've
been using the 6th generation ipad for 2
years now and it's my main go-to device
for illustrations and designs since then
i've never looked back on using my wacom
tablet
ever again
starting with the older ipad i've been
using most of the time i like that it's
light and it's easy to bring around with
this entry-level ipad the experience has
been great and if cost isn't a concern
this is a great place for anyone to
start off from in terms of performance i
haven't encountered any issues while
using it so it's been a comfortable
drawing tool to work with drawing in an
ipad in general is great because it's
very convenient in the way that i no
longer have to repair a large case of
tools and materials like pens markers
canvas i don't even see a point in
bringing all these things out if i have
the ipad procreate on ipad is very
beginner friendly and has easy to
understand tools in addition to the
familiar ipad controls i spent my time
watching some youtube video tutorials
and i was ready to go only recently i've
been given the new 4th generation ipad
air to play around with and the upgrade
has been quite significant in terms of
hardware and ergonomics the fourth
generation ipad air has a 11 inch screen
and is perfect for more immersive
experience
in fact it has a cleaner look
and with the extra screen real estate
the design experience has hit another
level of fun
so how's the viewing experience of the
fourth generation ipad air and the
regular ipad
truth be told sensitivity
pretty much the same
visuals
about the same
doesn't feel like anything is
compromised when it comes to
illustration the ipad s display is not
that much superior to older gen ipads
but with that said the ipad air's
responsiveness is
slightly
slightly better than older gen ipads
and that's due to the hardware upgrades
but
i'm not gonna go through all that
so overall for drive there's no
significant difference between the ipad
air
and older gen ipad what's very cool here
is that the ipad air has magnets around
its chassis
these magnets are used in four primary
ways a way to firmly attach accessories
onto the device's back as an apple
pencil attachment which also charges it
and it also helps you attach a smart
connector like this magic keyboard which
makes the ipad look like it's floating
in mid-air
this makes for a very user-friendly and
accessible device
almost feels like the device is helping
you beyond its basic functions
hello skynet
with all its cool features it's
surprisingly lighter than it looks
only being about 500 grams of course
after equipping it with this magic
keyboard the weight doubles to one
kilogram transferring data is always
convenient due to the automatic
procreate backups via cloud
alternatively airdrop has always been an
option for files that are left behind
which is also instantaneous i was also
surprised that the quality of works and
designs did not depreciate during the
transfer making this a very capable
device in terms of file transfers going
into the apple pencils the second
generation pencil
just
way better
the second generation pencil has a matte
surface and resembles more of a
traditional wooden pencil than its
predecessor the weight is denser and
it's ergonomic in the way that it feels
somewhat natural to hold the matte
finish of the pencil also makes for a
very comfortable grip that is also
easily cleaned and kept dry i could go
for long periods of time without letting
go of the pencil this is unlike the
first generation pencil where my hands
tended to get clammy or sweaty and the
process of drawing became increasingly
uncomfortable
it could be because of the glossy finish
of the pencil making it slip or cling on
to sweat whichever it is it does get in
the way of focus and makes the creative
process somewhat frustrating that's why
i'm very satisfied with the gen 2 pencil
in helping my creative process flow and
instead of charging the pencil via the
lightning port which can be a pretty
scary thing as the pencil is pretty
flimsy and i'm concerned that with one
wrong move i could just
break it
both ipads are quite good to use as
drawing tablets as compared to other
drawing tablets that might need more
equipment to be attached to it for it to
work such as the wacom and other art
tablets are also sometimes pc specific
so you need a large setup to work with
it and you're fixed at your workspace
this is not the case with the ipads
which you can bring out and around with
you maybe
you know in front of your subjects
having your subject be like all around
you it's a completely different
experience
when it comes to cost the ipad like this
6th generation or perhaps you've got
yourself the current 10 generation model
ipad
it is more than sufficient for your
needs to start off with but if you have
the extra cash the ipad air is the way
to go especially with the extra thrills
such as the convenient magnetic charging
gen 2 apple pencil
and magic keyboard and its price to
performance just knocks it out of the
park as for myself the ipad air is
definitely my go-to drawing device and i
can picture myself using it for a very
long time
well that's it for the video we hoped
you enjoyed it and if you liked it
please give us a thumbs up and if you
haven't already please consider
subscribing and smash that bell icon
stay updated with the latest geeky news
reviews and unboxings until then this is
claire signing off
bye